ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING
WE HAVE ONE BILL
AB ONE FORTY NINE COOPER TO
CONSIDER TODAY AND ENJOY IT
EIGHT CONSENT RECOMMENDATION
I ALSO LIKE TO WELCOME THE
NEW MEMBERS APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AS MEMBERS ARE TYLER
DEEP NOT HERE HE GAVE REAL
THANK YOU HAVE SPLIT
YEAH
WE GOT TO DO
MEMBERS
WE CALL THE ROLL GONZALEZ
FLETCHER PRESENT BIGELOW BLOOM
BONTA BROUGH CALDERON CARRILLO
CHILD CARE DEEP EGGMAN HERE
GABRIEL GARCIA OBERNOLTE HERE
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK HERE WE'VE
YEAH IS THERE A MOTION ON THE
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
BIGELOW SECOND BY MISTER --
OBERNOLTE MA'AM SECRETARY WOULD
YOU PLEASE READ THE BILLS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR EVEN MORE
FORTY NINE COOPER CONFECTIONERS
APPROVED ON A ROLL CALL
THAT CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY